what's this one though it's a dance of
dragons a true telling by Grandma
that sounds like a proper story what's
it about it's story of the fight between
rhaenery Targaryen and her heart by the
Reagan for control of the Seven Kingdoms
both of them thought they belonged on
the iron throne
when people started declaring for one of
them or the other their fight divided
the kingdoms in Two Brothers Four
Brothers
dragons for dragons
by the time it was over
thousands were dead
and it was a disaster for the Targaryen
as well they never truly recovered
that's dragons
why is that a dance
it's just what they call it
made sense
I think it's poetic
you'd had to choose
between
who you've chosen
I wouldn't have chosen either
saw the choosing sides that made
everything so horrible sometimes a
person has to choose you have to wait
two years until the next episode of
House of the Dragon so now is the
perfect time for you to listen to the
audiobook on which house of the Dragon
is based and you can listen to it now
for free that's right you can listen to
Fire and Blood audiobook for free it's a
Targaryen history book on which house of
the Dragon is based written by George R
Martin it goes from aegon's Conquest
until the end of the dance of the
Dragons which will also be the end of
House of the Dragon you can now listen
to it for free with horrible trial using
our link which you can find in the
description of this video all you have
to do is go to the description click the
link sign up for free audible trial and
choose Fire and Blood audiobook go and
listen to a long and Rich Targaryen
history including the current and future
events of House of the Dragon for free
the dance began as many dancers do with
an old man and a young girl the queen
had failed to produce a son for her King
so he anointed his daughter the prince
rhaenyra as his Heir but years later the
king remarried and his new wife Queen
Allison of house Hightower gave him a
son
feeble and foolish the Old King refused
to change the succession he didn't even
see how his court had split into two
rival camps of blacks and greens after
the dressers of The Princess and the
queen had worn to some tourney
[Music]
one night a servant found the Old King
had died in his sleep and ran to inform
Queen Allison
protocol dictated that the bells would
be rung and a raven sent to Dragonstone
to summon the air princess rhaenyra for
her coronation
but Alison had other plans the Lord
commander of the kingsguards sir Kristen
Cole summoned the small Council to
inform them of the King's death so Otto
Hightower the hand of the king and
father to Queen Allison demanded that
the succession be settled immediately
the decrepit old men of the small
Council were confused the succession was
settled in their minds the Old King had
forced the Lords of Westeros to swear
fealty to princess rhaenira as his heir
but sir Kristen Cole rightly pointed out
that her son comes before a daughter
the council argued until dawn when the
master of coin finally stood up and
declared he would have no part of
treason so Kristen Cole wisely opened
his throat with a dagger ending the
debate
none were more surprised to hear of
Prince aegon's succession than Prince
aegon himself at first the fool rejected
the crown but his mother pointed out
that his sister rhaenyra would return
such loyalty by taking his head when
Ravens carried the news of aegon's
Coronation to Dragonstone princess
rhaenyra summoned her own black Council
with her was her uncle and husband Damon
Targaryen considered by many to be the
most dangerous man in Westeros
few Lords supported her but the greatest
of these was Corliss Valerian who
controlled the largest Fleet in the
realm and his Targaryen wife rhaenys the
old King's sister then there were her
five Sons although none grown to manhood
the pitiful assembly really combined
they couldn't match the power of house
Hightower alone but rhaenyra had dragons
Damon and rhaenys rode huge and
formidable beasts and three of her five
Sons were Riders as well
Dragonstone also housed six more Dragons
without Riders against this King aegon
had only four dragons of his own
dragons can burn a city
but only armies can take and hold it if
she was to Prevail Rainier had
desperately needed the support of the
few great houses not already sworn to
aegon
her eldest son jacaris flew to the veil
in the north her middle son lucaris flew
to the stormlands rhaenyra hoped that
the war would begin and if the gods were
good end with diplomacy
as always they weren't
go on pop and tell the bone mother that
the Lord of Storm's end is not a dog she
can whistle up as eamonn's false eye
gleaned at him the princeling fled the
castle and mounted his young dragon arax
the rain fell in sheets and great bolts
of lightning lit the world's bright as
day
arax was struggling to stay aloft in the
Gale when a roar shook the very
foundations of Storm's end
Eamonn grows through the clouds and
Below him the Monstrous Vega Prince
loucarist fell broken to be swallowed by
the waves
with his death the war of ravens came to
an end
and the war of Fire and Blood began
for a heard of her son's death she
collapsed
he considered ending the war right then
until a raven arrived from her husband
Damon
her son would be Avenged a son for a son
rhaenyra shipped her two youngest sons
across the narrow sea for their
protection
only for her youngest to return Days
Later clinging to the neck of his
wounded and dying Dragon he and his
brother had been set upon by an enemy
Fleet just off Dragonstone defying his
mother's command Ray near his eldest son
in Heir jacaris mounted his Dragon
Vermax and flew to rescue his other
brother and punish the enemy Fleet but
the Foolish Boy let Vermax be hooked
like a trout and dragged into the sea
where he soaked up even more arrows and
seawater his brother disappeared over
the horizon or beneath the waves no one
could say for sure
with the loss of four dragons rhaenyra's
only Advantage was fading luckily for
her over the centuries House Targaryen
had spilled more than blood on
Dragonstone
she promised gold and title to any of
the Targaryen bastards who could tame
the six uncleaned dragons on the island
these bastards were called the dragon
seeds though most were called supper and
perhaps the Dragons Were eventually
sated or bored but four of them accepted
Riders and were enlisted in rhaenyra's
cause
one day King's Landing looked up and saw
two dragons circling their foul City
Damon and rhaenyra had come for her
throne for the city was defenseless
Eamonn had taken the king's Army from
the city and worse he'd taken his Dragon
Vega
seeing that resistance was hopeless the
small Council surrendered the city the
Queen Mother Alison and the broken Queen
Helena
but not King aegon
somehow despite his wounds and delirium
he had vanished from the city
and so Queen rhaenira climbed the steps
and seated herself on the Iron Throne
Legend has it that as she left the hall
later blood trickled down her legs and
hands proving the Iron Throne had
spurned her nonsense
it's a chair made of steel blades
rhaenyra had wanted it all her life and
had sacrificed two sons for it
she likely gripped the damn thing too
tight
back in King's Landing Queen rhaenyra
didn't have much time to grieve for her
stupid husband the Mad former Queen
Helena flung herself From a Balcony to
be impaled upon the iron spikes lining
the motive maegor's holdfast
that night the city Rose and Riot
against rhaenyra demanding Justice for
Queen Helena and her murdered son among
other foolish peasant fantasies in the
midst of this chaos a one-handed fool
called The Shepherd began to rant
against dragons not just the ones of the
enemy but all dragons everywhere as he
pointed to the dragon pit above on the
hill he shouted they're the demons dwell
this is their city if you would make it
yours first You Must Destroy them by the
time the first of the attackers came
pouring in all four were roused awake
and angry nobody knows how many men and
women died that night who cares they all
should have trapped within the pit the
dragons could not fly instead a fort
with horns claws teeth and fire for
every man who died ten more appeared
shouting that the dragons must die one
by one they did finally the last
remaining Dragon broke her chain spread
her wings flew straight up at the great
Dome trying to flee already weakened by
dragonflame the Dome cracked under the
force of impact and then tumbled down
crushing Dragon Slayers and herself
High Atop The Red keep Queen rhaenyra
clutched her two remaining Sons to her
as she watched the end of a family's
might too afraid of the peasants to
defend her dragons at least her older
son Joffrey had a man's spine he stole
his mother's Dragon Cyrax and tried to
fly it to the dragon pit to save his
Birthright
stupid Beast didn't understand and
twisted beneath him fighting to be free
of the little boy
until it was
weeping for her lost son more than her
dragons rhaenyra abandoned the iron
throne and sold her crown to by passage
for her and her last son back to
Dragonstone
rhaenyra hoped to hatch more dragons
from the eggs in the castle
but when she landed the welcoming party
slew her guards and marched her and her
son at spear point to the castle to face
a dead man and a dying dragon
sister King aegon second of his name
called out to rhaenera rook's rest had
left aegon bent and twisted his once
handsome face puffy from milk of the
poppy with burn scars covering half his
body rhaenyra ever defiant told her dear
brother that she'd hoped he was dead
after you aegon answered
then Sunfire
bathed her in a blast of flame
devoured her in six bites when the sun
watched leaving the seventh and final
bite her lower leg
for The Stranger
two years until season two is a long
period but you can still stay in the
house of the Dragon World by listening
to Fire and Blood audiobook for free
house of the Dragon is based on Fire and
Blood book and covers the entire
Targaryen history starting from aegon
the Conqueror and his Conquest as well
as Meg or the cruel and other legendary
targaryens including the current and
future events of House of the Dragon go
and listen to it for free with horrible
trial using our Link in the description
foreign